on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
on Facebook and uncensored tonight
protesters prepared a celebrations for
the king's coronation we just had a day
off for once but the country first I'll
take on two of them he spent seven
decades in training with this moment but
his King Charles the man to mend an
entitled monarchy we'll debate that with
a sparkling panel of serrano fines and
Andrew Morton
and then Elon Musk says civilization
will collapse and we don't start having
more children yes more I'm joined by the
Silicon Valley Hot Shots who say they
are breeding to save mankind
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening for London welcome to Piers
Morgan on sensor Brits will celebrate
the coronation of King Charles in many
weird and wonderful ways on Saturday
after all a royal occasion brings out
Britain and his Bonkers best there's the
Royal super fans the decked in Union
Flags who've already begun camping
outside the mall some for the last week
just for a fleeting glimpse of his
majesty and of course Camilla is Queen
in the gold State coach
well thousands of neighbors will stuff
their faces and wave their flags at
Street parties firstly Patriots will
guzzle 36 million pints in a weekend of
merriment for the Monarch many of them
in pubs especially rebranded as the
Charles and Camilla there are the Royal
scarecrows the Mad Hatteras the
transatlantic Travelers and of course
the great many people who just have a
nice long weekend with extra day off
work now you might not share the
Patriotic further that incites our best
eccentrics to pay homage to the crowd
you might not agree with the monarchy
but the common theme with all the above
is that it's celebratory and joyful
and a bit of escapism
and harmless if you're making a King
Charles Mosaic from a thousand tiny
Union Jacks have a tattoo of Camilla in
your foreign I salute you if you're
tired of the royal circus and you're
spreading this weekend in your shed I
understand that too what I don't
understand are people like this
uh we just can't be we can't afford to
be wasting money uh on the Royals which
operate effectively as parasites
parasites really
1600 members of the Republic were like
called Republic will Target the
procession by wearing yellow t-shirts
radical anti-royalist students known for
defacing statues and invading Windsor
Castle one of them is here are planning
events across the country many
thunderous dissenters are traveling to
the Capitol to wave placards screaming
not my king well bad news is your king
whether you like it or not and nobody
cares about your principles stand I mean
they might but just have a day off
it is true that some people aren't that
interested in the coronation and don't
think we should have a monarchy it's
also true that the large majority of his
country and all the recent polls do and
last time I checked in a democracy the
majority wins
I can guarantee you that categorically
nobody wants to see a bunch of
attention-seeking protesters ruining the
big day you've got to write to protest
absolutely fundamental right to protest
as part of a democracy boy do we know
about your right to protest but to do it
in the middle of an enormous National
Security operation in front of the
world's cameras when we are showing the
very best of our country the pomp the
pageantry the Majesty the Brilliance of
our military Armed Forces at their very
best and the biggest procession we've
seen since the Queen's coronation we
should be proud of this and if you're
not proud of it we'll just be quiet
have a day off
go and paint your nose green again
whatever you want to do then guess
yourself at night but just let us have
this day
and we can have the debate again all
over next week if you want well join me
now from the no more Royals movement is
Human Rights Campaign or republican
Peter tachel and talk TV presenter
Richard Tice defending the nation today
all right Rhys
you're wearing a t-shirt which I think
explains your view no more royalty by
the way you're completely entitled to
where in a free country and you're
totally entitled to not want a royal
family my question which I posed in the
monologue there yeah can't you just have
a day off I mean seriously because
it's not just about the monarchy
it's not the entire world watching what
are often really great days for Britain
to solve something which is positive
rather than for the last few years an
unbelievable slew a totally of
negativity so it's disappointing that
you think all of us activists are really
boring and miserable it's totally
understood or just prove my theory okay
uh first of all you said nobody cares um
why am I here if nobody cares the
reality is the public opinion in Britain
is totally shifting we are looking at
only a third of the young people think
of the monarchy should should continue
and in the general in the general public
we're looking at 52 only 52 support the
future of the monarchy that's the lowest
that's ever recorded only 52 voted to
leave the European Union but we did
because that's called a democracy right
and the majority Point here is that's
massively Fallen within the last decade
it's clear when it's trend is going now
I I do appreciate your point about um
about joyous events right uh that's
important to me I really strongly
believe that all of the activism we ever
do needs to involve giving back to our
communities and bringing like positivity
to people's lives what we do is about
creating hope this weekend I'll be an
Oxford putting on an event for my
community uh there'll be live music my
friends band is gonna play
um and we'll be chatting to people how
they feel about the monarchy about
republicanism they'll be food and
importantly we'll be raising money for
local homelessness Charities I live well
this is this is all extremely virtuous
but of course you and your partner
Imogen uh earlier uh this year jumped
into the king's bed at Windsor Castle
the pose for photographs while reading
Prince Harry's book spare and eating
junk food we've got pictures of you
there what was the what was the purpose
of that so the purpose is to get people
talking about get people like you pissed
off and shocked basically really want
people to be talking higher calling race
I mean no you seem perfectly nice young
lady
you've been incredibly well and if I may
say so expensively educated right I mean
you've had a lot of privilege in your
life uh with scholarships absolutely yes
right I mean you've gone to some
extremely expensive schools so just to
talk about that I'm going to attack you
by the way I've done the same with my
kids I'm just saying I'd like to talk
about that you have enjoyed a lot of
privilege absolutely and yet you seem to
be incensed by privilege so yeah that's
a really important issue to me
um how do you square the two things I
mean yeah I I absolutely have had a
massive amount of privilege in my life
I'm not upper class Royal Rich does it
ruined you absolutely that privilege can
I just could we just go to the protest
you did ask me a question about that
yeah the point was to communicate just
sort of how this juxtaposition between
modern Britain and what that looks like
and this archaic weird set of
Institutions that just doesn't sit right
with that
um we wanted to bring attention to the
issue because if we hadn't done that I
wouldn't be on this show talking about
it and I wouldn't have the opportunity
to say to your listeners we need a
republic we need a better democracy in
the Brit in
so
can I go into those issues because I'd
really really just give me a name about
the specifics okay so they will do a
better job as president then Elizabeth
did his Queen for 70 years yep so I I
appreciate your point it's absolutely
true there are bad give me a name
I'm not the entirety of Britain I don't
know any name of it who would be a good
president
uh what I want to communicate I'm asking
you because in America we're about to
have Biden Trump for the second time
what is a daughtery female man who can't
remember his own name the other one is
indicted on criminal charges that is
where purely elected I appreciate your
point if I could just respond to it uh
they're absolutely a bad and good
politicians in any political system
that's true there are really good
presidents uh Ireland has a really good
presidential system there are many semi
semi-presidential systems there are
Parliamentary presidential systems what
I want to communicate here is if you're
talking about uh we can't trust the
people to vote for their president you
can't call yourself a Democrat that's
fine that's an argument you're entitled
to make but that doesn't sit with the
principles of proxy can I just say this
last week I'm giving you a good old buzz
you can come back in a minute Richard
you talk about positivity we've got
billions of people around the world this
weekend who are going to look at Britain
at its best at its finest at its most
historic this event will create hundreds
of millions of pounds to the UK economy
the royal family the every single year
create in terms of brand value the
latest stats about 2 billion a year
right the royal family they give 85
percent of their assets which is called
the crown estate to the British taxpayer
which they don't have to do but they do
making huge profits all of the offshore
wind farms are on the land owned by the
Monarch it's a billionaire of profits
that goes to the British taxpayer it's
one of our greatest Global assets people
admire it they're respected people are
wanting to join the Commonwealth all
because of the royal family a president
who comes every four or five years
creates no brand value at all first and
then we can talk about presidential
assistance after you talked about Pride
right and I really appreciate you
raising that the reality is only nine
percent of britons are a great deal
excited about the coronation what about
what about the billions of people around
the world let me just finish that point
uh I think we have far better sources of
pride in Britain than an unelected give
me one there are so many things give me
one my community
I'm talking about the people that I
interact with on a day-to-day basis
who's your community
who is your community
what are you I don't get why you're
trying I don't know what you mean what
do you mean your community my community
is the people around you I know you're
you're young you're a young student at
Oxford right having a wonderful
education usually expensive education
again it's great good well done well
done on more privilege and elitism but
let me ask you let me ask you who is the
community
you're talking about
in in
that people at Oxford University no
actually I spend a lot of time working
outside of the University
you've been very patient go ahead you're
intending to protest aren't you on
Saturday
yeah why a peaceful protest yeah it will
not disrupt
people will be able to celebrate we're a
small group around Trafalgar Square the
whole rest of the route will be for
people who want to celebrate the
coronation we exactly ruined the party
we accept their right to celebrate and
we hope they will respect our rights why
would you go to someone's dinner party
and just jump through the window and
start shouting at them while they're
having a meal if you didn't agree with
what they're eating no but so why would
you do this to a big party for the
country when everyone's having a lovely
time even if you don't agree with it
can't you just take a day off
that Peter answer it's because very
simply
Charles is not only King he is a head of
state yeah and even if people believe in
him being King he should not be head of
state why not the highest public office
in the land should not be inherited by a
privileged family but Peter which should
be open to anyone of Merit to be elected
by the people but what executive power
does the Monarch really have now well it
has huge huge reserve powers
the answer is none
every law has to be signed by the
Monarch that is purely a functional
thing which happens okay and it's
mandate they don't ever say no so they
have no executive power what they do
provide is soft power they are one of
the few things we have left in this
country frankly right now where we are
world leaders there is no monarchy to
rival ours there is nobody in the world
as a nation that can put on the kind of
show we're going to put on on Saturday
and frankly I am proud of that I think
it's a great asset to our country you
are whitewashing the reality of royalism
the Monarch has a secretive power called
King's consent which has been used over
a thousand times to block or modify
legislation affecting the Royals that is
giving them derogations in terms of
employment rights for their 700 servants
giving them derogations for health and
safety D giving them derogations for
Environmental Protection they pay no
inheritance tax Charles inherited almost
a billion pounds from his mother he
didn't pay a single penny tax that is so
unfair by the society
Peter let me finish let me finish you
talk about money
the financial benefit of the monarchy
they washed their face to put it as a
colloquial phrase where they don't
really cost us anything it's estimated
it might cost us 1p a day let's be very
clear that is not true they own the
crown estate they should not own the
crown they've owned it for a thousand
years for the British people they give
us 85 of the profits of the crown estate
and they're given additional billion
pounds a year on the offshore wind farms
alone
Richard because I'd really like to talk
about the economy uh recent estimates
are 345 million pounds that's how much
the monarchy costs us now yes some of
that is The Sovereign Grant
no it's not actually there's The
Sovereign Grant which absolutely you're
right which comes from there comes from
their own estate finish my point Richard
uh yes The Sovereign does come from the
estate thank you which are not personal
property they uh
would you just let me finish my point uh
however that cost um The Sovereign Which
is far smaller than the 345 million
pounds I've quoted uh it does not
include the cost here's my point again
oh my God let me finish my race why do
you care I just I would why do you care
if you don't agree with the monarchy or
the Royals why don't you just find
something more interesting to be angry
about would you just let me go after
cost of living crisis or whatever it may
be talking about piss local government
security those are all excess costs that
the cost of the monarchy is far bigger
than what it's quoted the estimated and
that is money that should be let me jump
back in let me just respond to that let
me just respond we are having a
conversation
I'm posting a show with three guests
it's not just about you it was revealed
today that they reckoned the hundred
thousand tourists coming to London just
London for this coronation that all that
they will do in the time they're here
will bring in 450 million pounds along
with all the extra Hospitality so the
capital alone so look my point Peter is
this is that I believe they watch their
face financially in which case the
argument shouldn't be about the money
part of it it should be a little bit
about the money you've said that
bringing all this money
commercialism I'm removing the money
from the argument because I think the
bigger argument is whether we should
have an unelected head of state is a
more interesting debate to me than the
semantics over the money which I think
they actually pay for themselves
on that one point who would you have as
president that'll be up for the British
people give me give me an option I think
baroness Helena Kennedy QC or Casey
would be a fine president
a human rights lawyer who's done
exceptional work to defend the rights of
the British people and no tourists
around the world is going to come and
see baroness that no one's ever heard of
you're talking absolutely
millions of pounds of Revenue to this
great country
creates those profits is the Royal
Estates
agreement I cannot no I cannot go back
to your notebook we haven't got time but
it's been a good debate thank you come
back another time it hasn't been a
debate you haven't let me finish a
single point actually you've done more
talking than any of the other guests you
haven't let me so the words you're
looking for are thank you it's been good
to see you Peter always good to see you
I'll look out for you on Saturday with
your banner I'll be uh commenting on
this for Fox in America if I see you
I'll give you a shout out there's my
friend Peter with his not in my name
Banner Richard it was good to see you
too Chris calm down count to ten
there'll be another chance
go back to Oxford get yourself lucky
privileged education together huh you're
one of the most privileged young ladies
in the country almost right up there
with Prince William uh he said the
longest apprenticeship in history but is
King Charles a man to rescue an in
battle monarchy Andrew Morton so Ronald
finds what a panel that is well join me
next
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view God Save the
King
[Music]
thank you
you're thinking it
we're talking about
[Music]
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view God Save the
King
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to business organization
with less than 48 hours away from King
Charles being officially proclaimed as
our Monarch the first coronation of my
lifetime and most people's lifetimes new
king and queen be leading other senior
Royals and rehearsals for Global
spectacles been 70 years in the waiting
but as King Charles demonic to made a
difficult moment for the monarchists
about to pull that delays there's just
14 of Brits think you'll do a better job
than his late mother and to be honest
I'm surprised it's even right because
she was a unparalleled Monarch the
greatest of all time in my view well
Jordan just discuss is the Royal
biographer Andrew Morton and shortly
speaking to the exploring close friend
of the King sir Randolph finds as well
so Andrew Well great to see you hi I
can't think of a better man to put all
this into perspective
um it's it's an incredible it's like
following Alex Ferguson at Manchester
United or Sinatra at the Sands isn't it
for poor Charles he's waited all this
time and of course the longer his mother
went on the greater her reputation and
Legacy became until the point where she
is now acknowledged as the greatest
Monarch in history yes and then yeah
indeed and the Twilight of her Reign I
think was the finest part of it yes in
the speech speeching the Kobe pandemic
we'll meet again speech still brings
tears to mind yes I agree now and I
think and uh and she showed her a real
sighter myself that she'd never shown
before so so ironically when she passed
she was at her popularity what was that
his Zenith but quite frankly I mean you
know we've we've seen we've all seen uh
King Charles over the years and we've
seen his development from
um a little boy the last coronation to
to today so he's had enough training
well he's had the greatest
apprenticeship in history yeah the big
difference between the Queen's
coronation and this one is that when
Elizabeth was crowned in 1953 people
talked about a new Elizabethan age yes
it was a step change and so on this is
just business as usual it's it's it's
people in their 70s getting mad I mean
you know when when Elizabeth became
Queen Churchill was in tears because he
thought you know she couldn't cope with
the job of course King Charles can
because he knows all the people and
there's all the people in Europe all the
people in all the politicians in Britain
you as we know had a very close
with Princess Diana you wrote that
extraordinary book
what would she have made of this do you
think because she said
the famously in the in the Panorama I'm
not sure he'd be up for the top job or
even wanted the top job well you know
she said to me right from the start with
one of the early interviews that
um he would that she would never become
Queen but she'd have a rough road and
that she didn't think that he would ever
become king and what she what she wanted
was to see uh Charles go off to Tuscany
with what he called what she called then
his lady and leave her to look after the
shop as it were with Prince William and
guide him to the throne so skip a
generation so she's the one who started
that debate off which has kind of
resonated down through the decade how
would she have felt if she was still
alive at seeing Camilla get crowned
queen well the 1997 version of diamond
before she passed would have been uh
Furious but for the simple reason that
you know in her conversations with the
Queen the queen said oh Charles will
never marry Camilla of course she got
that wrong as well so in those days she
would have been absolutely mortified but
25 years on you would hope that she's
found a new Love A New Life a new
purpose in life some peace perhaps and
and I was intrigued looking at the guest
list that Andrew Parker both is going to
be in the congregation and I thought to
myself now that's a shrewd move that's
that's an amicable divorce Diana I
wonder if Dinah would have been there
she wouldn't have been there no she'd
she'd have been somewhere else she'd
have been uh abroad presumably you know
visiting a hospital Duke of Windsor he
wasn't invited he went to Paris sat and
and did a running commentary from the TV
screen with in front of us that's right
his friends
um I want to bring in Serana fires uh we
we've now made a contact with saranov
great to have you on Cheers Morgan on
censored uh thank you very much indeed
for joining us I want to start with a
clip of Prince or King Charles now of
course but he was Prince Charles when he
said this about you
he wanted to do the things that hadn't
been done by other people
to achieve the others
if you had too much imagination you'd
never do these things I don't think
you wrote I'm asking if I'd be
interested in helping brother nice to
have people who have proper eccentrics
he had this absolute drive and
determination
well surrender for he doesn't get better
than that this is a man who's about to
be crowned king of our country bestowing
you with these uh amazing tributes how
did that make you feel
well he was great I mean I'll give you
an instance
um we used to go to Highgrove to brief
him in the 70s 90s as to the next uh
Expedition world breaking attempt he
would be patron of but he wouldn't agree
to be Patron without us going to
describe everything that's going on on
that next Expedition and on one occasion
at Highgrove he said yeah that sounds a
good idea but who are we raising money
for this time and I said well sir I'm
afraid you know we never have raised
money and he said well I wouldn't have
been your Patron if I'd known that and I
said well who do you want to raise who
do you want to raise money for and he
said I'll let you know and I'm a couple
of months later he said Ms multiple with
sclerosis and Takata long story short
now all these years later we're up to
19.8 million for UK Charities as a
result of Prince Charles's one comment
amazing you know him well much better
than most people what do you think think
of the biggest
misunderstandings about him as a man
people really don't seem to know what a
wonderful honest humble character he is
and he's got a great sense of humor a
great sense of Duty but you know he's
had a lot of people
um against him Auntie monarchy and so on
and he lives in a democracy and he knows
his place as it were and we've been very
very lucky having him I can remember
being told that the Special Air Service
who are in charge of the first journey
around Earth vertically that we were
doing with Prince Charles as the patron
he came out to Australia to say hello he
got on the ship at Greenwich where we
set out and he steered all the way down
the Thames he came to visit us when we
had a show of all our sponsors at
farnborough inside farnborough and here
with his Equity who was scared stiff was
at the wheel heap of good flight he of
it was a twinata ski plane with wheels
at the time and and as he landed on the
snow and ice at Farmer at that time he
thought oh that is nice I only did it
three times and his Equity was terrified
him a bit and I I actually know Camilla
better who I'm a big fan of I think
she's been an amazingly stoic Rock in
his life
um it's very difficult I was talking to
Andrew Morton here about this when
you're following a monarch as great as
his mother and of course he had to take
over whilst mourning the loss of his
mother coming quite soon after the death
of his father
um these are seismic changes in any
man's life both personally and
professionally do you think he has the
the tools I mean you're one of the most
resilient men in the country dookie has
the tools to not just come through that
but to thrive and be a the king that
he's always wanted to be
I think so but I'm no good at hypothesis
into the future what what we'll go for
and against you know we just do not know
but if anyone stands a very good chance
of it with a good sense of humor and a
good sense of humility as I told you and
honest he will be the right the best
possible one that we could have we had a
young lady on earlier who was very
exercised about the idea of a monarchy
wanted to get rid of the monarchy have a
republic there is a republican whiff in
the air amongst many countries in the
Commonwealth uh and a little bit of it
here as well when you justify our
monarchy to people if you get into that
kind of debate with people what are the
best selling points do you think of why
we should continue to have one
well we are a democracy and so if we
vote for having a king rather than one
of the many other Alternatives then yeah
you're going to get lots of people
against it lots of people for it some of
their reasons seem to be very reasonable
but uh with the bottom line is that we
remain a democracy and we stand up for
any other democracies like zelenskis and
uh you know the monarchy normally but
not uh always of course is democratic
yeah and and to those who say that the
whole idea of an unelected
head of state unelected monarchy
presiding over our Democratic process
what's the best justification for a
monarchy do you think
I think it's the way we inherit things
and always have in the UK I don't know
about France and anywhere else but in
the UK inheritance through a certain
line uh is what we've been accustomed to
all these Generations
yeah I think that's right Andrew let me
bring you back in here yes um stability
and continuity yeah I mean when you get
when you get asked come on then what
explain why we why Britain should have
this ridiculous farce of unelected
people living in palaces with servers
what's the best answer well it is a
constitutional monarchy that's that's
what Churchill always used to think it
was a constitutional monarchy it wasn't
a tyranny it wasn't a rule by one man
and it's it's a it's kind of like
explaining the game of cricket to an
American they don't
it's one of those things that it's just
it's evolved over over the years and it
can do with some uh reforming I mean I I
notice now that King Charles is is
reforming the way that they uh have
their palaces and houses
and there's there's all there's you know
there's a lot that can be done but at
the same time do you uh live by the
premise that this is the best uh that
we've got for our country and I think
the answer is yes you recently starred
in series five of the crown or rather
you you were played by an actor yeah
Andrew still yeah I've got one up on you
we have a clip we have a clip I wasn't
in the crowd yet it's still time let's
take a look at this
as a royal correspondent I've had a
ringside seat to this marriage for a
while
most recently home
second honeymoon
and I can't stand to see someone being
crushed like this essentially his being
I do
take this book that's being written
with the prince of wales's cooperation
maybe not him directly but his friends
for sure
we want what they see is the truth about
that I'll let him be told
it won't be pretty
[Music]
I just want to do what's right for her
she's like a sister to me
can I give you my word no one will ever
know she had anything to do
I mean a bit too much hair I think to be
an accurate I have to say if she'd have
lived I would still be saying today she
had nothing to do with the book because
she was as it was a deep throat the
diner once gave me a 90-minute interview
on the phone when I was headed to the
mirror about her eating disorders after
visiting a clinic and then the next
morning issued a statement to press
Association expressing her Fury at these
intrusive Revelations which had all come
from her
so she was a Mercurial character uh
where will you be on the big day I'll be
outside Westminster Abbey yeah okay and
uh I'm looking forward to it and a quick
word about Prince Harry what reception
do you think he's going to get what does
he what does he deserve well he deserves
it's a state occasion not a family
occasion and he deserves a hard bench
presumably sitting at the back of the
the uh made of what he's been doing
well I mean Diana did I own biography
with me so she would have been perfectly
content especially as Harry gave Camilla
a good kicking yeah that's probably true
and remember a lot or not you know Harry
speaks a communes with his mother and
doesn't make any decisions without
referring to her right uh saranov where
will you be on the big day on Saturday
I'm absolutely miserable a long time ago
when there was no coronation date fixed
I got fixed up for giving lectures in
various parts of the north Scarborough
and around that area and the contract
you know can't be undone so I'm I'm
hoping that our Patron Prince Charles
will understand well King King Charles
as he now is
yeah but we've been used to him being
Prince Charles for all these years well
we're used to you being so run off but
it can't be long before you're promoted
to Lord fines can it
it can because I didn't get a sir anyway
it was my dad and he got it from his
granddad and so I don't like using it
very often because I didn't earn it do
you understand what I mean I do but you
do earn it because you're a great
National Treasure so whether you think
you earned it or not I think you do and
it's great to have you to run off on the
program thank you very much
no thank you for asking me and uh making
about a wonderful man Prince Charles
King Charles
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
great to see you and Andrew thank you
very much indeed really appreciate you
coming in thank you and the big day of
course is Man City leads well let's talk
to all football don't insert into
private agree I also found that I can't
go there too painful still to come Ross
until the world is overpopulated and the
planet will simply explode with human
beings but others don't agree with that
a new Silicon Valley movement says the
opposite is true and we have to have
more children to save mankind Elon Musk
thinks this is a massive crisis that is
about to unfold we'll talk to a couple
after break who are breeding like the
proverbial rabbits because they believe
this
foreign
[Music]
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mug we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about breakfast
if you want the real crown then tune in
to talk TV for a right Royal point of
view God Save the King
[Music]
thank you
foreign
you're thinking it
we're talking about
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the fun team and Paul what is good
about Britain I agree our King if you
want the real crown then tune in to talk
TV for a right Royal point of view God
Save the King
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to previous organizers the
UN says there'll be 11 billion humans by
the year 2 100. sparking warnings of
overpopulation with famine disease
conflict and even complete societal
collapse on the polar opposite side of
that debate though are the pronatalists
Elite Silicon Valley couples who say
birth rates are going to fall and we
should all breed more to save Humanity
Elon Musk is their most famous Advocate
and he's one of the smartest guys in the
world the world's richest man and one of
the cleverest as 10 of his own kids and
claims population collapse due to low
birth rate is a much bigger risk to
civilization than global warming
meanwhile down the road in Montecito
that world-renowned expert on everything
Prince Harry told Vogue in 2019 that he
capped a number of kids he's planning
with Megan to help save the world to two
maximum he said he said I've always
thought this place is borrowed and
surely being as intelligent as we all
are at which point I'm afraid he lost me
um so anyway let's move on from Harry's
place because once he says that he loses
the argument one couple at the center of
the pronatalist movement and the
backlash to it are Simone and Malcolm
Collins from Pennsylvania currently have
three children plan to expand their
family to seven and they join me now
from Philadelphia well welcome to both
of you so uh Simone let me start with
you if I may
um because you're doing the physical
side of this intensive reading um
it's very interesting because I've
listened to Elon Musk about this and he
is absolutely adamant this is the
biggest threat actually along with
artificial intelligence to mankind is
the reverse of what most people think
it's actually a case of the population
levels tumbling to a level which is
going to endanger the planet explain to
people who think that's ridiculous why
that is a real situation
yes as as soon as societies basically
reach a level of modernity where there
is prosperity gender equality high level
high levels of Education
populations start to drop below
replacement rate that's a pretty serious
problem if it seems like modernity and
all the things that we consider to be
good like women's rights like Prosperity
like good quality of life seem
incompatible with flourishing humans it
seems wild to me that we live in a world
today we're not a single country or
culture except for maybe Israel has
found out how to maintain a stable
population alongside Prosperity gender
equality and education this as like a
civilization is probably something we
should start talking about once I heard
I was having you guys on his guests I
didn't read a lot about this and it
seems to be that the graph the graph
continues to rise population until
around the middle of a century but then
it could it could start to fall
precipitously after that
yes if you look at fertility rates today
the only countries that really have
above repopulation fertility rates are
where the average salary is under 4 000
pounds a year or five thousand USD a
year so you're really only seeing high
fertility rates in desperately poor
countries right now if you look at the
developed world the average fertility
rate is only around 1.5 and we need 2.1
just to keep stable populations okay and
someone you know I know that you're
planning to have seven children I think
you've got three on on your belt
literally
um how fast do you want to have the
seven what's the is the clock ticking
here
absolutely yeah we need to have them
basically as quickly spaced as possible
so we're going in for our next uh our
next round essentially next month and
we're going to have more than seven if
we can basically until my uterus is
forcibly removed in a botched surgery
I'm gonna keep going
I mean it is we laugh about it but
there's a very serious point to this and
it's fascinating because the more I've
dug into it after actually Elon Musk
said what he said The more interesting
it becomes and look it is an argument
which is argued vehemently both ways you
know there are a lot of people who
believe the complete opposite but there
are a lot of smart people who think this
is a real doomsday thing coming around
the corner
yeah I mean I think we need to look at
how quickly fertility rates can collapse
when I started caring about this I was
working as a venture capital in Korea
and I had to constantly plan out the
future of their economy at South Korea's
current fertility rate for every 100
South Koreans there will be six
great-grandchildren we're looking at a
94 population collapse coming back to
places like the US and the UK it felt
like traveling two decades back in time
like I was in some sort of uh sci-fi
world and I got a chance to try to raise
the flag before it was too late because
when you hit a place like Korea where
Now 60 of the population is above the
age of 40 it's probably too late for
them to turn the situation around and
then there's all these economic problems
you can say what we can solve this with
immigration but then what you're doing
is you're making the developed World
Reliant their economies reliant on
keeping Africa poor or the African
countries poor that have these high
fertility rates and that's not a good
place to put the world in and then you
talk to the us about this and they go we
can solve this with immigration but as
of 2019 by the un's own statistics
collectively South America Central
America and the Caribbean fellow Liberty
population rate so I think people are
just they're not aware of how far this
problem has progressed
new countries in the world today yeah
and the numbers are pretty startling
actually uh I mean Simone the answer
clearly is we have to go back to massive
gender inequality right
no I mean the whole reason why we're
advocates in this entire space is we
really want a future in which there is
gender equality and if we don't take
measures now the future is one with
massive gender inequality right
basically the future of feminism
requires on more feminist people having
kids and raising them in a durable
culture that is feminist and this is
what was so funny if there was I'm sorry
I'll run out of time I'm actually going
to get you guys back another time
because this is a really interesting
debate honestly I'm I'm I find this
really intriguing and your great guest
so thank you very much for joining me
now and we're going to do a bigger
debate on this down the line after after
our coronation's out the way but but
thank you Simona Malcolm I appreciate
you joining me thank you very much
thank you we're excited too
we need the Royals to keep breeding and
we don't have a monarchy it's a very
least they're going to keep going uh
uncensored next I'll debate all this
with my my panel look at this panel
waiting expectantly
um back to the kitchen so YouTube uh
we'll debate and Catherine Jenkins will
perform again a wonderful National
foreign
[Music]
experience tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view God Save the
King
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
experience tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mug we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
our King if you want the real crown then
tune in to talk TV for a right Royal
point of view God Save the King
[Music]
Christmas
hello Darlings we have a fabulous show
coming up for you at nine o'clock we
really do on the tour tonight will in
case of the fresh face of the royal
family as they wow coronation crowds in
SoHo their new demands for an apology
and reparations from King Charles and
we're talking about the university
that's cut the word woman from its
maternity leave policy and Sharon's
really annoyed about it that's all in 10
minutes
[Music]
welcome back to uh Facebook I'm going to
talk to these International editor
Isabella talk to the contribute to Paula
Ron Adrian okay what did we make of this
Paula this it's it's an interesting
debate right I mean are we all getting
this completely wrong is it actually
that we're going to be underpopulated so
no is a short answer to that question I
appreciate it you know because I I've
also can read peers like you and I also
did my research like you
um and what we are not doing by
listening to the Collins is this
wonderful and romantic as they sound
what we're not doing is taking into
account the other factors that need to
be taken into account to live on this
planet by what like climate change like
the fact that we are going to see the
mass migration of people due to climate
change what's going to happen when the
droughts hit what's going to happen when
the there's no more fish in this
Etc how is that going to affect the
reality of prosperous countries heading
towards massive underpopulation that's
that's a separate argument I think you
are actually touching on something much
more sensitive there which is that
essentially the population is rising and
going to continue Rising quite steadily
up for the next about the next 80 years
something like that and then it's going
to slightly fall back that's not what
Elon Musk I think what they're really
saying is that the population isn't
Rising among the right sort of people
and I also think very very rarely for
you you slightly missed a trick with
your interview with them because you
didn't bring up the impact of the whole
trans thing and all these people who are
now voluntarily kind of giving up their
reproductive system well that does bring
me neatly actually to the University of
the art in London has been criticized
for removing the word woman from its
maternity leave and menopause
information it will now apply apply to
all genders they prefer to use
individual person and people because
they want to be inclusive Isabel
I mean you can only go through the
menopause if you've got female
reproductive parts apparently not so
well no that is just a fact I mean a
trans man could go through the menopause
but how many of those will there be in
that well because the trans man is a
biological female exactly so they may go
through the menopause but are you going
to alter here's my point about this
entire language
why does all language for women
and women's health issues have to be
irrevocably changed at the altar of
trans activism sorry a tiny percentage
exactly of trans people will have any
involvement with any of this 99 of women
want to be called women they want to be
called mothers they want to be told
they're having a menopause women what's
happening to the country when the word
woman is now being erased so I think the
the issue is it's about gender
neutrality isn't it it's about finding
terminology that will be able to include
everybody
to not offend the trans Community are we
deliberately offending 99 of women where
are their rights to be called women
seriously I mean I it's very very
excitable and for us I find this whole
issue utterly enraging and I'm not even
a woman we need to be calm for us to
have this debate I don't think we need
to speak because the one screaming
loudest I'm affecting all the change
they're bullying everybody into going
along with this Total Insanity well I
want the word woman to be saved I like
women I like you women I don't
understand why every woman isn't
storming the rampart why is it called
the menopause are they now going to say
it has to be called the themapause or
something like that I mean you know
perhaps but please if I can answer your
question you can try when we look at
gender neutrality it is about trying to
find words that are inclusive and I get
that I get that in terms why do you have
to well because chairman is not an
inclusive term you could have chair a
chair who was everything
what about manhole Batman what about
manhole and what about manhole what
about does that have to go what about
dustman does that yeah
a man
to be a person
why are you being homeless
I don't think it does is and that's the
point about gender neutrality you don't
you don't believe this
we can tell she's talking absolute
nonsense she doesn't believe it all
right I believe she believes I've got to
leave you because we've got Catherine
Jenkins a Bonafide woman waiting to sing
I vow to thee my country that's it for
me I'll be back tomorrow night with a
Friday special about the coronation Keep
It Uncensored
[Music]
alive
by things
[Music]
the best
the love that pays
[Music]
we may not sleep
ing
[Applause]
[Music]
silence
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
experience tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about Britain royal family our King if
you want the real crown then tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
God Save the King
[Music]
thank you
if you're thinking it